monsieur pieds-noirs l'amendement est
retiré merci je passe à l'article 1 bis
trois amendements identiques de
suppression d'abord le 124 madame poncet
mange
merci monsieur le président face à
l'inflation donc l'urgence sociale
appelle des mesures fortes de
revalorisation des salaires afin de
permettre le maintien pérenne du pouvoir
d'achat cela passe notamment par la
nécessité d' accord de branche et
d'entreprise dynamique actant des
augmentations de salaires ainsi que par
l'augmentation du smic
car comme l'europe le souligne la dares
en 2021 concernant la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre dans une trentaine de métiers
en tension l'apaisement des difficultés
de recrutement devra passer par je cite
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
la revalorisation des salaires dans
certains métiers plutôt que des réformes
de l'assurance chômage
en conséquence le retour de
l'attractivité de beaucoup de métiers et
de branches passe par des rémunérations
digne en plus de meilleures conditions
de travail mais le projet de loi on l'a
vu of plutôt les moyens d'éviter
l'augmentation des salaires en
encourageant les primes défiscaliser
désocialisés et alors en résonance avec
le gouvernement cet article ajoutées en
commission introduit une déduction
supplémentaires forfaitaire des
cotisations patronales pour les
entreprises à partir de 20 salariés
c'est à dire de plus grandes pas en
dessous à partir au titre des heures
supplémentaires poursuivant et
accélérant la fuite en avant de
réduction du salaire socialisé
générateur de droit or ce nouveau
dispositif d'exonération ne permet en
rien d'aider les salariés mais les
contraint à toujours travailler plus
pour maintenir un pouvoir d'achat en
régression tout en creusant toujours
plus les déficits publics c'est un
cercle vicieux pour le groupe écologiste
ni les salariés ni les comptes publics
ou les comptes de la sécurité sociale ne
doivent servir de variable d'ajustement
face à la pression inflationniste
en conséquence nous proposons de
supprimer cet article additionnel je
vous remercie
c'est le 156 qui le défend monsieur guay
merci monsieur le président
seul ministre mes chers collègues nous
demandons également la suppression de la
défiscalisation et de la désocialisation
des heures supplémentaires adoptées par
notre commission des finances surtout
qu'on a un précédent ça va vous faire
plaisir mes chers collègues est-ce que
ça a été instauré à appeler ou en 2008
par nicolas sarkozy
et
évidemment on a des études
sur ces questions on a cité la dares le
fc eux aussi a fait une étude assez
intéressante je vous en lit quelques
passages elle a dit que ça va augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat
concrètement des salariés mais la
contrepartie ça surtout entraîné
l'allongement de la durée du travail
puis à deux questions je sais que vous
alliez être celle ci puisque vous parlez
souvent de des comptes publics ça a
coûté aux comptes publics avec la baisse
des cotisations et l'exonération d'impôt
quatre milliards et demi
pas une petite question
et puis en termes d'emplois ça a été
négatif puisque seraient supprimés entre
53000 et 95 mille emplois en quatre ans
donc effet quasi nulles pouvoir d'achat
en tout cas moins que le salaire et puis
en termes économiques et en terme
d'emploi le bilan est plutôt négatif
donc nous proposons de ne pas réitérer
cette expérience malheureuse
au nom du gouvernement le 450 merci
monsieur le président c'est le deuxième
amendement qui traduit une des
divergences entre le gouvernement et la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat nous proposons de supprimer cet
article 1er bis qui prévoit une
déduction forfaitaire de cotisations
patronales sur les heures
supplémentaires
limiter une part forfaitaire et j'ai
bien compris les auteurs de l'amendement
en particulier sur les 25 % de
majoration le gouvernement considère que
ce n'est pas une mesure de thouars
d'achat que ça peut être éventuellement
une mesure de compétitivité le ministre
de l'économie a dit ce matin être
disponible pour et voir si cette mesure
peut être circonscrite à certaines
entreprises et je considère comme je le
dis ce matin que cette mesure relève
plus du père et faire que du projet doit
pouvoir d'achat dans la mesure où le
plfr qui vous sera soumis dans quelques
jours est aussi le texte qui permet
d'augmenter le plafond de 100 milles à
7500 euros d'heures supplémentaires
faisant l'objet d'exonérations fiscales
et sociales pour les salariés donc c'est
une demande de retrait au bénéfice de
cette discussion ouverte avec la mise et
l'économie
merci alors à vis de la commission je
considérais monsieur le ministre que
l'avis du gouvernement est évidemment
favorable aux amendements puisque trois
fois identique merci monsieur le
président alors effectivement c'est un
article 1er bis que nous avons introduit
en commission 1 dans l'objet vise à
réduire les cotisations patronales sur
la majoration de salaire au titre des
heures supplémentaires c'est important
de préciser alors simplement les uns les
autres nous rencontrons tous un certain
nombre de salariés on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de salariés qui souhaitent
faire des heures supplémentaires soient
effectivement parce que ils ont envie de
les faire et c'est bien légitime mais
soit également parce qu'ils ont une
véritable difficulté de pouvoir d'achat
et ça rentre donc pleinement dans ce
texte et c'est plutôt vertueux comme
comme en tout cas comme comme besoin et
je trouve qu'il faudrait l'encourager
deuxièmement de rencontre aussi des
employeurs qui peuvent être dans la
difficulté et en l'occurrence l'article
tel qu'il a été proposé vise à rejoindre
la solution pour ces deux difficultés
monsieur guy en ce qui concerne le coup
vous avez énoncés je rappelle simplement
que cet article d'abord et je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure ne concerne que la
majoration des heures supplémentaires
donc on ne parle bien que des 25% pour
les entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
et de surcroît nous avons renvoyé le
montant de la rémunération par décret au
gouvernement donc on a bien entendu le
chiffre que nous avait annoncé mais on
est bien loin si selon effectivement les
discussions qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
des chiffres tels que ceux que vous avez
de vous les avez vous avait énoncé du
type 4 milliards d'euros et enfin ce qui
concerne le fait de renvoyer cet
amendement au plf monsieur le ministre
simplement tout ce qui concerne les
cotisations sociales a toujours été
traités par la commission sociale et
dans le cadre du plfss donc il ya toute
légitimité pour que nous puissions
traiter cet amendement est en
l'occurrence est donc un avis
défavorable pour les trois amendements
monsieur le président puisque nous
souhaitons effectivement que sept
article demeure dans le texte
merci j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe l'est
républicain sur les trois amendements
identiques de suppression je vous
rappelle que l'avis de la commission est
défavorable que l'avis du gouvernement
est favorable il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
demande à voter
le scrutin est clos
sur les amendements identiques 124 156
454 compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs go politique est notifiée à la
présidence nombre de votants 343 nombre
de suffrages exprimés 305 pour
l'adoption 105 contre 200 le sénat n'a
pas adopté et je passe à deux
amendements identiques d'abord le 113
qui le défend oui je vous en prie
merci monsieur le président alors cet
amendement de macau l'ex de sylviane
noël a pour objectif de redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux salariés ce qui est
bien l'enjeu du texte que nous examinons
il permet de réduire le coût des heures
supplémentaires et complémentaires pour
les employeurs sans minorer la
rémunération des salariés ceux ci
continuerait en effet apercevoir la
majoration afférentes aux heures
supplémentaires mais les cotisations
patronales de sécurité sociale serait
calculée sur la seule rémunération de
base hors majoration du aux heures
supplémentaires les employeurs seraient
ainsi incités à proposer des heures
supplémentaires à leurs salariés
je vous remercie
amendements identiques le 263 monsieur
la gourde et défendu monsieur le
président merci
avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements et merci monsieur président
alors je comprends tout à fait l'esprit
un de ces deux amendements néanmoins
tout est question d'équilibré dans la
vie la proposition que nous avons fait
c'est effectivement d'avoir une
exonération bien entendu comme vous sur
la majoration au titre des heures
supplémentaires nous avons renvoyé en
décrire au gouvernement la possibilité
de moduler ce montant en fonction
effectivement déséquilibre à tenir sur
l'intégralité du texte et du plfr donc
en l'occurrence c'est ça la vie soit une
demande de retrait soit un avis
défavorable sur les deux amendements
merci avait du gouvernement
l'amendement présenté s'il était adopté
et appliqué représenterait un coût pour
les finances publiques d'un milliard
deux cents millions d'euros donc dans la
même dans la mesure où nous sommes
défavorables
à la déduction forfaitaire proposé en
commission vous imaginez comme
défavorables à une déduction totale sur
la majoration
eh bien je vais mettre voit le 113 et le
263 identique avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
et qui est contre
ils sont rejetés le 157 madame apourceau
poly
merci monsieur le président donc par cet
amendement de repli nous demandons la
suppression des exonérations de
cotisations sociales des heures
supplémentaires le rapport de la
commission des affaires sociales parce
que parfois il ya quand même des
rapports est particulièrement éclairant
s'agissant des conséquences financières
de ces exodes
exonérations de cotisations sociales
page 38 du rapport de notre collègue
frédérique puissat d'après les
informations recueillies par le
rapporteur une exonération totale de la
majoration salariale aurait un coût de
800 millions d'euros en année pleine est
donc de 200 millions d'euros pour le
dernier trimestre de 2010 22 vous ne
pouvez chers collègues de la droite vous
indigner de la baisse des moyens des
hôpitaux et des fermetures de services
dans vos territoires est proposée par ce
par amendement près d'un milliard
d'euros de pertes de recettes pour la
sécurité sociale
et même si l'état s'engage à compenser
cette perte de recettes pour la sécu
vous savez bien que c'est d'autant
d'argent au moins pour les services
publics en conclusion le gouvernement à
trouver une majorité pour le soutenir
dans le travailler plus pour gagner plus
votre proposition c'est aussi moins
d'emplois moins d'hôpitaux moins
d'écoles moins de services publics pour
toutes ces raisons notre amendement
demande le maintien des cotisations
sociales sur le paiement des heures
supplémentaires
je vous remercie merci à vis de la
commission apporte sa présidence et un
amendement qui vise à amoindrir
la proposition que nous avons fait donc
forcément que la commission est
défavorable à cette proposition
respectueuse au passage comme
gouvernement
c'est un amendement de repli sur
l'amendement de suppression du
gouvernement donc sagesse
allez je me vois le 157 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission sagesse du
gouvernement qui est pour
rester calme
et bien aller pas d'excitation inutile
dur à d'autres sujets
merci qui votent contre allez levez la
main l'a révélé au et tout le monde dort
[Musique]
si au bout de trois heures vous êtes
tous dans cet état qu'est ce que ce sera
demain soir
vous vous bonifier avec le temps oui
j'en doute pas
il est rejeté je vais passer au vote sur
l'article 1 bis j'ai une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe l'est
républicain
le scrutin est ouvert
la voter
le scrutin est clos
sur l'arctique
il compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs groupes politiques et notifié
la présidence nombre de votants 343
nombre de suffrages exprimés 291 pour
l'adoption deux cents contre 91 le sénat
a adopté
après l'article 1 bis le 36 monsieur
cabanel oui merci monsieur le président
nous proposons que les salariés dont les
revenus sont inférieurs à une 6 smic
ceux qui sont les plus pénalisées par
l'uniformité du taux de csg puissent
bénéficier d'un allégement cette mesure
permettrait d'accroître le pouvoir
d'achat des salaires